>> Jesse: CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
SO WHEN A MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS
DRUG ADDICT WHO HAS COMMITTED
CRIME AFTER CRIME IN HIS STATE
AND NEVER DEPORTED ATTACKS PAUL
PELOSI WITH A HAMMER GAVIN
NEWSOM HAS TO BLAME ANYBODY BUT
HIMSELF AND GAVIN NEWSOM THINKS
JESSE WATTERS IS TO BLAME FOR
PAUL PELOSI GETTING HAMMERED.
>> I HAVE SEEN THE
DEHUMANIZATION OF NANCY PELOSI I
DON'T THINK ANYONE HAS BEEN
DEHUMANIZED CONSISTENTLY I
WATCHED THIS ONE GUY JESSE
WATTERS OR SOMETHING ON FOX NEWS
WHAT HE HAS BEEN SAYING ABOUT
PAUL PELOSI THE LAST SIX MONTHS
MOCKING HIM CONSISTENTLY.
DON'T TELL ME THAT'S NOT AIDING
AND ABETTING ALL OF THIS.
IT'S SEWING THE SEEDS CREATING A
CULTURE AND CLIMATE LIKE THIS.
LOOK ONLINE.
LOOK AT THE SEWAGE THAT IS
ONLINE THAT IS THEY AMPLIFY ON
THESE NETWORKS AND IN SOCIAL
MEDIA TO DEHUMANIZE PEOPLE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI AND OTHER POLITICAL
LEADERS.
>> Jesse: FIRST OF ALL, GAV
THANKS FOR WATCHING LET'S SET
THE RECORD STRAIGHT PAUL PELOSI
GOT DRUNK AND NEARLY KILLED
SOMEONE WITH HIS CAR.
THE NAPA COUNTY D.A. HEY ALLI WE
REPORTED THAT PAUL PELOSI GOT
SPECIAL TREATMENT AND TRIED TO
BRIBE THEM WITH A DONOR CARD.
THERE IS STILL QUESTIONS WE
HAVE.
GAVIN NEWSOM THINKS IF YOU MOCK
A DEMOCRAT IT PUTS THEM ON AUTO
TARGET LIST.
SO GAVIN IS SAYING THAT BY
SAYING HE USES MORE HAIR GEL
THAN JOHN TRAVOLTA IN GREECE
IT'S GOING TO TO MAKE PEOPLE
SHOW UP ARE PAMMERS.
WE HAVE ALWAYS SAID GAVIN'S
BIGGEST FLAW NOT VERY SMART.
THE DERANGED DRUG ADDICT THAT
TALKS TO FAIRIES AND LIVED ON A
SCHOOL BUS DIDN'T WATCH
"PRIMETIME" AND HEAD OVER TO
NANCY'S HOUSE WITH A HAMMER.
DID HE READ THE EIGHTH HE WASN'T
THERE FOR PAUL.
HE WAS GOING THERE FOR NANCY.
IF ANYTHING, GAVIN NEWSOM HAS
DONE MORE AID AND ABET THIS
ATTACK ON PELOSI THAN ANYBODY.
HOMELESS CRIMINAL AND ILLEGAL
ALIEN.
DEPAPE OVERSTAYED HIS VISAS FOR
YEARS.
COMMITTED CRIMES.
CALIFORNIA IS A SANCTUARY STATE,
SO HE WAS NEVER DEPORTED.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
WHO IS MORE AT FAULT HERE?
THE GOVERNOR WHO DIDN'T DEPORT
THE DERANGED DRUG ADDICT FELON
THOUGH THINKS IS HE JESUS OR THE
NEWS GUY WHO FAIRLY COVERED
PAUL'S DUI CASE?
I THINK WE BOTH KNOW THE ANSWER.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ME THEY ARE
TARGETING.
JOE BIDEN MANAGED TO BLAME THE
ENTIRE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> YOU CAN'T CONDEMN THE
VIOLENCE UNLESS YOU CONDEMN
THOSE PEOPLE CONTINUE TO ARGUE
THE ELECTION WAS NOT REAL THAT
IT'S BEING STOLEN, ALL THE
MALARKEY OUT THERE BEING PUT OUT
THERE TO UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY.
YOU CAN'T JUST APOLOGIZE AND SAY
THE VIOLENCE IT.
UNDERMINES PEOPLE MENTALITY
DISRESPECTS.
CONDEMN WHAT PRODUCES THE
VIOLENCE AND THIS TALK PRODUCES
THE VIOLENCE.
>> Jesse: THEN THE MEDIA BLAMED
THE PAUL PELOSI ATTACK ON
JANUARY 6TH.
>> POLICE SAY ZIP TIES WERE
FOUND AT THE SCENE JUST LIKE THE
ONES FOUND ON THOSE WHO WERE
HUNTING NANCY PELOSI AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6TH.
AND THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
SIMILARITY.
>> ZIP TIES.
HE HAD ZIP TIES WITH HIM.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> AND DUCT TAPE AND WAS ASKING
FOR NANCY, THAT THIS WAS A
VIOLENT ACT TARGETED AGAINST THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
THERE A PERFORMATIVE NATURE OF
THE POLITICAL VIOLENCE WE HAVE
SEEN.
WE SAW IT ON JANUARY 6TH.
IT WAS VERY SIMILAR TO
JANUARY 6TH.
>> REPORTED THE SAME CHANT WAS
USED BY THIS GUY THEY HAVE IN
CUSTODY THAT WAS USED ON JANUARE
U.S. CAPITOL.
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
>> Jesse: DO YOU KNOW WHO ALSO
HAD ZIP TIES?
NICHOLAS ROSS SKI, SOUND
FAMILIAR IN THE LIBERAL FANATIC
TO TRIED ASSASSINATE BRETT
KAVANAUGH HE ALSO HAD A HAMMER
AND GUN AND CROWBAR.
FOR SOME REASON THE MEDIA FORGOT
ALL ABOUT THAT STORY.
THE DEMOCRAT ACCUSED KAVANAUGH
OF RACISM, GANG RAPE, DRUGGING
WOMEN AND THEN LEAKED THAT HE
WAS GOING TO OVERTURN ROE V.
WADE AND A MAD MAN ZIPPED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY READY TO KILL.
DID THE MEDIA BLAME THEMSELVES?
DID THE MEDIA TONE DOWN THEIR
LANGUAGE?
NO.
THE MEDIA DROPPED THE STORY LIKE
A BAD HABIT.
AND NOW CBS IS DEMANDING
REPUBLICANS DROP THEIR ADS
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
>> REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES HAVE
SPENT MORE THAN 116 MILLION ON
ADS THAT MENTION SPEAKER PELOSI
BY NAME IN THIS CYCLE.
IF THIS IS ABOUT THE ISSUES, WHY
DON'T YOU MAKE IT ABOUT THE
ISSUES?
WHY NOT DEPERSONALIZE IT?
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY ABOUT THE
ISSUES.
>> WE ARE 8 DAYS OUT.
DON'T YOU THINK THIS NEEDS TO
CHANGE?
WHY NOT PULL SOME OF THESE ADS?
>> Jesse: I SEE.
SO NO ONE IS ALLOWED TO
CRITICIZE NANCY'S POLITICS EVER
AGAIN, ESPECIALLY NOT BEFORE A
WAVE.
WE ARE JUST SUPPOSED TO LAY DOWN
AND LET DEMOCRATS WIN AND PULL
THE ADS.
THEY ARE NOT MENTIONING THAT
DAVID DEPAPE'S EX SAID HE WAS
OBAMA GUY AND PROGRESSIVE.
BUT THE MEDIA AND LEFT ARE
JUMPERRING ON THE REPUBLICANS
ARE TO BLAME WAGON.
WHEN THE BERNIE BRO SHOT STEVE
SCALISE, DID YOU HEAR ANY OF US
BLAMING BERNIE?
BUT THE SAME CAN'T BE SAID FOR
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA WHO
CELEBRATED ATTACKS ON
REPUBLICANS LIKE WHEN RAND PAUL
GOT HIS RIBS CRACKED BY HIS
NEIGHBOR AND MSNBC GUSHED ABOUT
HOW IT WAS ONE OF THEIR FAVORITE
STORIES.
>> NEW DETAILS TODAY ON THE
INCIDENT THAT LEFT SENATOR RAND
PAUL WITH SIX BROKEN RIBS --
THIS MIGHT BE ONE OF MY FAVORITE
STORIES.
>> Jesse: DON'T YOU LOVE WHEN
REPUBLICAN SENATORS RIBS GET
CRACKED.
IT WAS ONE MUCH THEIR FAVORI